Our story begins in 1835, or maybe 1935, or maybe the last time you woke up with a hangover from the wine at the gas station. You know, Franzy's evil cousin, and you asked yourself, is this normal? Is it normal to feel this way? Let's work our way backwards. Today on the show, we have the incredible comedian, writer, and podcaster, Jamie Loftus. I can't remember a time in my life when I didn't know what Alcoholics Anonymous was. We talked about it at home like a friend that lived in the same neighborhood. Dad was going to a meeting tonight, so wait outside or in the hallway of the high school until it's over, then walk through the cloud of cigarette smoke and friendly conversation when the AA hour,
我们的故事始于1835年，或者可能是1935年，又或者是你上次因为加油站买的酒而宿醉醒来的那天。你知道，弗兰齐（Franzy）那个邪恶的表亲，你当时问自己，这正常吗？这种感觉正常吗？让我们倒叙一下。今天节目里，我们请到了了不起的喜剧演员、作家兼播客主持人杰米·洛夫图斯（Jamie Loftus）。我不记得我生命中有什么时候不知道“匿名戒酒互助会”（Alcoholics Anonymous，简称AA）是什么。我们在家里谈论它，就像谈论住在同一个社区的朋友一样。爸爸今晚要去开会，所以我得在外面或者高中的走廊里等着，直到会议结束，然后穿过那片烟雾缭绕和友好交谈的人群，当AA的一小时，
and it was always exactly an hour, was up. I can count on one hand for my entire childhood, a time where a close to, family member drank in front of the kids, even though pictures from before I was born were so full of alcohol that you couldn't always make out the ready-faced younger versions of my dad, aunts, and uncles. Later, when I went to dad for advice, he could rarely avoid just saying it directly. Take things one day at a time. Find the serenity to accept the things I could not change, the courage to change the things I could, and say it with me now, the wisdom. to know the difference.
而且总是刚好一小时，结束的时候。在我的整个童年里，我一只手就能数得过来，有哪次是亲近的家庭成员在孩子面前喝酒的，尽管我出生前的照片里充满了酒精，以至于你有时认不出照片里那些面色红润、年轻版的爸爸、阿姨和叔叔们。后来，当我向爸爸寻求建议时，他很少能避免直接说出来。过好每一天。找到宁静去接受我无法改变的事情，找到勇气去改变我能改变的事情，现在跟我一起说，找到智慧去分辨两者的区别。
These meetings were important, I thought. They'd protect our family from whatever it happened, and they and my mom's patience would keep us altogether from an evil I had never seen or tasted. Even though I wasn't totally sure what an alcoholic's anonymous meeting was. Two weeks before my dad died in 2024, he hit an incredible marker, 30 years sober from alcohol.
我想，这些会议很重要。它们会保护我们的家庭免受任何可能发生的变故，它们和我妈妈的耐心将保护我们免受一种我从未见过或尝过的邪恶侵害。尽管我并不完全确定匿名戒酒互助会会议是什么。在我爸爸2024年去世前两周，他达成了一个了不起的里程碑：戒酒30年。
The first five years or so, spent going to AA meetings every single day. The influence AA had on my family was gigantic in ways I was told about and ways it would take me years to understand, influencing not just how my family behaved, but how we thought. But as a kid, the only tactile evidence I had that AA existed was something I was kind of obsessed with, this little album where dad kept all his sobriety chips. He, along with most AA members, started accruing these at his first meeting, right after he got out of the three days of detox that his health insurance covered. You collect sobriety chips the fastest in your first year clean, at 24 hours, 30 days, 60 days, 90 days, all the way up to a year in most groups,
最初的五年左右，他每天都去参加AA会议。AA对我家庭的影响是巨大的，有些是我被告知的，有些则需要我花几年时间才能理解，它不仅影响了我家人的行为方式，还影响了我们的思维方式。但作为一个孩子，我唯一能触碰到的AA存在的证据是我有点痴迷的东西，那个爸爸存放所有戒酒筹码的小相册。他和大多数AA成员一样，在第一次参加会议时就开始收集这些筹码，就在他结束了医疗保险覆盖的三天排毒期之后。在戒酒的第一年，你收集戒酒筹码的速度最快，24小时、30天、60天、90天，在大多数小组里一直到一年，
and often annually after that. My dad was never precious about belongings, but these chips were really important to him. The rare things that my brother and I were not allowed to touch. They meant something. And if the way everyone else acted was an indicator, it was mom's support and dad's commitment to Alcoholics Anonymous that was the reason that I had a relationship with him at all. Fast forward to this year, my dad was gone, I was in my 30s, and I had to face the fact that I developed a shaky relationship with alcohol. And I found myself on a work trip to Iowa with one of those little white plastic chips in my hand. One of my own, one even flimsier than the 24-hour chip and dad's album.
之后通常是每年一次。我爸爸从不把财物看得太重，但这些筹码对他来说真的很重要。这是我和哥哥不被允许触碰的稀有物品。它们意义非凡。如果其他人的行为可以作为指标的话，那么正是妈妈的支持和爸爸对匿名戒酒互助会的承诺，才是我能和他保持关系的原因。快进到今年，爸爸走了，我30多岁了，我不得不面对一个事实：我和酒精的关系变得不稳定了。我发现自己在去爱荷华州的出差途中，手里拿着那枚白色的小塑料筹码。这是我自己的，比爸爸相册里那枚24小时筹码还要单薄。
Our stories were really different. I hadn't hit bottom. There was no relationship with a spouse or a child on the line. I just knew I had to make a change. And even though I'm far from alone there, there's around 30 million Americans that have some degree of alcohol use disorder. I felt pretty embarrassed about it. And when I started looking into how that little white chip got there,
我们的故事截然不同。我没有跌入谷底。没有配偶或孩子的关系受到威胁。我只是知道我必须做出改变。尽管我远非孤身一人，大约有3000万美国人患有不同程度的酒精使用障碍。我对此感到非常尴尬。当我开始研究那枚白色小筹码是怎么来的时，
I found a story that was so profoundly and infuriatingly American. It's the kind of story that really makes you want to take a drink. Embude in this little chip is a hidden history that contains centuries of Americans' relationship to morality, to religion, and even to gender, to identity. That's a pretty potent piece of plastic. From 99% Invisible and BBC Studios, This is a history of the United States and 100 objects.
我发现了一个如此深刻且令人愤怒的美国故事。这是一种真正让你想喝一杯的故事。这枚小筹码中蕴含着一段隐藏的历史，包含了几个世纪以来美国人与道德、宗教，甚至性别和身份的关系。这是一块非常有力的塑料。来自《99%隐形》（99% Invisible）和BBC工作室，这是《美国历史与100件物品》。
I'm Roman Mars. Today, the Alcoholics Anonymous, sobriety chip. Alcoholics Anonymous wasn't born in a void in 1935. It was a response to a massive, mostly failed political movement that proved once and for all that morality is impossible to legislate. Luckily, American legislators have since learned not to do that, a fact you might agree with if you cannot read, hear, or see. I'm talking about American Prohibition, which ran from 1920 to 1933, about a year and a half before the first AA meetings took place. Now, I didn't learn about prohibition in school, in spite of hearing a lot about the history taking place around it. Women's suffrage passes the same year as Prohibition, and the issue hovers around rapid industrialization, World War I, the Great Depression, and a massive early 20th century wave of immigration from Europe to the United States.
我是罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）。今天的主题是：匿名戒酒互助会的戒酒筹码。匿名戒酒互助会并非诞生于1935年的真空中。它是对一场大规模、基本失败的政治运动的回应，这场运动证明了道德是不可能通过立法来实现的。幸运的是，美国立法者们此后学会了不再这样做，如果你不能阅读、听见或看见，你可能会同意这一事实。我说的是美国禁酒令，它从1920年持续到1933年，大约在第一次AA会议召开前一年半。现在，我在学校里并没有学过禁酒令，尽管我听到了很多关于它周围发生的历史。妇女选举权与禁酒令同年通过，这个问题围绕着快速工业化、第一次世界大战、大萧条以及20世纪初从欧洲到美国的大规模移民浪潮。
But today, with the exception of my close personal friend Ken Burns' docu-series on the topic, Prohibition has been boiled culturally down to two images. The Gangster and the Flapper. The Gangster. Usually Al Capone or a thinly veiled version of him is violent, powerful, and endlessly charismatic, appearing everywhere from Scarface to the Godfather to Tintin. The flapper is his counterpart, a liberated woman of the jazz age. Think gentlemen prefer blondes and Daisy Buchanan's partying in these dank, glamorous speakeasies, drinking martinis, and completely free of the responsibilities of the home.
但今天，除了我亲密的朋友肯·伯恩斯（Ken Burns）关于这个主题的纪录片系列外，禁酒令在文化上被简化为两个形象：黑帮分子和摩登女郎（Flapper）。黑帮分子，通常是阿尔·卡彭（Al Capone）或他的隐晦版本，暴力、强大且极具魅力，出现在从《疤面煞星》到《教父》再到《丁丁历险记》的各个地方。摩登女郎是他的对应物，爵士时代的解放女性。想想《绅士爱美人》和黛西·布坎南（Daisy Buchanan）在那些潮湿、迷人的地下酒吧里聚会，喝着马提尼，完全摆脱了家庭责任。
But there's so much more to this time when the law of the land constitutionally banned production, import, transport, or sale of alcoholic beverages. Passed through the 18th Amendment and enforced by the cruel and inefficient Wolsted Act, it's weird that we don't talk about prohibition more often. After all, it's the only constitutional amendment that's been repealed, ever. So why does it get lost in the shuffle? Well, I think it partially because everybody thinks they know everything about it.
但那个法律在宪法上禁止生产、进口、运输或销售酒精饮料的时代，远不止于此。通过第18修正案并由残酷且低效的《沃尔斯泰德法》（Volstead Act）强制执行，奇怪的是我们不常谈论禁酒令。毕竟，这是唯一被废除的宪法修正案。那么为什么它会被遗忘呢？嗯，我认为部分原因是每个人都觉得自己对它了如指掌。
You know, everyone just thinks, oh, we've heard all those gangster stories a million times and we don't want to listen to them anymore. This is Joya DiLaberto, author of Firebrands, the untold story of four women who made an unmade prohibition, a book that tackles this question head on. She and most historians are sure about one thing. Prohibition was a crummy idea and it didn't work. I mean, it failed because it was just a bad idea from the get-go. I mean, it's incredible that a constitutional amendment was passed instituting prohibition.
你知道，每个人都想，哦，我们已经听过一百万遍那些黑帮故事了，我们不想再听了。这是乔亚·迪拉贝托（Joya DiLaberto），《煽动者：四个制造并终结禁酒令的女性的未讲述故事》（Firebrands, the untold story of four women who made an unmade prohibition）的作者，这是一本正面解决这个问题的书。她和大多数历史学家都确定一件事：禁酒令是个糟糕的主意，而且它没起作用。我的意思是，它失败了，因为它从一开始就是个坏主意。我的意思是，通过一项实施禁酒令的宪法修正案真是不可思议。
The 18th Amendment went into effect in 1920, but this was after close to a century of temperance activism. And while prohibition fails for a million reasons we can explore, what's true is that prior to prohibition, Americans drank much more alcohol. In 1830, the average person drank three times. more than they did by the 2010s, the equivalent of 88 bottles of whiskey a year, and the culture around alcohol was marketed almost exclusively to men. Saloons became the social center of communities in the back half of the 1800s. There were around 250,000 of them in the U.S. at their peak, and were a place where men could get a hot lunch, connect with translators and job prospects, cast their ballots, meet their unions, and of course, get blackout drunk on the alcohol of
第18修正案于1920年生效，但这是在近一个世纪的节制运动之后。虽然禁酒令因我们可以探讨的一百万个原因而失败，但事实是，在禁酒令之前，美国人喝的酒要多得多。1830年，普通人喝的酒是2010年代的三倍，相当于每年88瓶威士忌，而且围绕酒精的文化几乎完全是针对男性的。19世纪后半叶，酒吧成为社区的社交中心。在鼎盛时期，美国大约有25万家酒吧，那里是男人们可以吃热午餐、联系翻译和工作机会、投票、会见工会，当然，还可以喝得烂醉的地方，喝的是
whichever brewery owned the joint. And with the popularity of saloons came the country's first temperance group, the Washingtonian Society, established in Baltimore in 1840. The Washingtonian's philosophy was pretty close to what AA would be saying nearly a century later. It was composed of men with drinking problems, sharing their experiences in a group meeting and pledging abstinence. Here's writer T.S. Arthur on the group. They were assembled in a drinking house in city, six men, well-advanced in years, who had for a long time been confirmed to drunkards, or at least so wedded to the love of strong drink. They had met accidentally, but in the mind of each there was a feeling of sorrow for his enslaved and wretched condition, a strong desire to
任何拥有该场所的酿酒厂提供的酒。随着酒吧的流行，全国第一个节制团体“华盛顿人协会”（Washingtonian Society）于1840年在巴尔的摩成立。华盛顿人的理念与AA近一个世纪后所说的非常接近。它由有饮酒问题的男性组成，在小组会议中分享他们的经历并承诺戒酒。这是作家T.S.亚瑟（T.S. Arthur）对该团体的描述：他们聚集在城里的一家酒馆里，六个上了年纪的人，他们长期以来一直是公认的酒鬼，或者至少是沉迷于烈酒的爱。他们是偶然相遇的，但在每个人的心中，都有一种对他被奴役和悲惨处境的悲伤感，一种强烈的渴望
rise out of it, yet a painful, hopeless sense of weakness. The Washingtonians counted tens of thousands of men as members. It was so popular at the time that Abe Lincoln, and gave a speech to them in 1842. But after a few decades, the group's popularity waned. The culprit for their failure, it's been speculated, was the Washingtonian's entanglement in unrelated progressive political causes. And put it in that because A.A. makes a very different decision in that department. Those progressive causes happen to be the abolition of slavery,
摆脱它，但又有一种痛苦、绝望的软弱感。华盛顿人协会拥有数万名成员。它在当时非常受欢迎，以至于亚伯拉罕·林肯（Abe Lincoln）在1842年还对他们发表过演讲。但几十年后，该团体的受欢迎程度下降了。据推测，他们失败的罪魁祸首是华盛顿人协会卷入了无关的进步政治事业。我之所以这么说，是因为AA在这一方面做出了非常不同的决定。那些进步事业恰好是废除奴隶制、
the feminist movement, and the larger temperance movement. And these causes overlapped constantly throughout, the 19th into the 20th century. Frederick Douglass was a famous teetotaler, framing alcohol as a tool of oppression to dull the minds of enslaved people by their oppressors. If we could but make the world sober, we would have no slavery, Douglas said in 1845, going on to explain that all great reforms go together. And given that we only ever really see women as flapper set dressing in this era, I was very surprised at how the push to ban alcohol directly overlapped with the first wave of the American women's movement. The drive for the vote was completely tied up with the drive to abolish liquor.
女权运动和更广泛的节制运动。这些事业在19世纪到20世纪期间不断重叠。弗雷德里克·道格拉斯（Frederick Douglass）是一位著名的禁酒主义者，他将酒精描述为一种压迫工具，用来麻痹被压迫者的思想。道格拉斯在1845年说：“如果我们能让世界清醒，我们就不会有奴隶制。”并继续解释说，所有伟大的改革都是相辅相成的。考虑到我们在这个时代只把女性视为摩登女郎的装饰品，我非常惊讶于禁止酒精的推动力是如何直接与美国第一波妇女运动重叠的。争取投票权的运动与废除酒类的运动完全捆绑在一起。
Joya makes the case that the history of prohibition cannot be extracted from feminist history. Women found political power in the movement when most other forms of power were unavailable to them. On both sides of prohibition, women of all political persuasions are at the top of organizing. A woman was in charge of enforcing prohibition and a woman who was the catalyst for getting it repealed. And I thought this is a woman's story. So what attracted women to the temperance movement in the first place? It was a matter of pragmatism and safety. Historically, they and their children were the victims of alcoholic men.
乔亚认为，禁酒令的历史不能从女权主义历史中剥离出来。当大多数其他形式的权力对女性不可用时，她们在运动中找到了政治权力。在禁酒令的两边，各种政治倾向的女性都处于组织工作的顶端。一位女性负责执行禁酒令，而另一位女性则是促成其废除的催化剂。我想，这是一个女性的故事。那么，是什么吸引女性首先加入节制运动呢？这是一个实用主义和安全的问题。从历史上看，她们和她们的孩子是酗酒男性的受害者。
Women didn't really drink much in the 19th century, and men drank rivers. Drinking was an enormous problem for American families because the water wasn't safe. And so men on the farm, for example, they'd have big vats of beer that they would drink from instead of water. And they'd be drunk all the time, and they would hang out in bars. And bars were the place in the cities where men went to politic and pick up. cores and getting fights and so on. And so male drinking was an issue that interfered with women's lives and the harmony of women's lives. Temperance was the rare cause that allowed roles in political leadership to women, while still presenting itself as a matter that affected the home.
19世纪女性其实喝得不多，而男人喝得像河水一样多。饮酒对美国家庭来说是一个巨大的问题，因为当时的水不安全。所以，例如农场里的男人们，他们会有大桶的啤酒，他们会喝啤酒而不是水。他们会一直喝醉，他们会泡在酒吧里。酒吧是城市里男人们去搞政治、搭讪、打架等等的地方。所以男性饮酒是一个干扰女性生活和女性生活和谐的问题。节制运动是少数允许女性担任政治领导职务，同时又表现为影响家庭事务的运动。
The Women's Christian Temperance Union was the biggest women's organization in the world in the late 1800s. And once a lot of these women got a taste for activism, many went on to advocate for other causes. And then they realized that they were never really going to be able to do anything about drinking if they couldn't vote because they couldn't get rid of the drunken politicians. They couldn't get laws passed that would limit the hours of the bars and so on and so forth. So it was when they realized that they needed some political clout to get rid of booze that the fight for feminism really geared up. But they didn't just fight for the vote.
“妇女基督教节制联盟”（WCTU）是19世纪末世界上最大的妇女组织。一旦这些女性尝到了行动主义的滋味，许多人便继续倡导其他事业。然后她们意识到，如果她们不能投票，她们就永远无法在饮酒问题上做任何事情，因为她们无法摆脱那些醉醺醺的政客。她们无法通过限制酒吧营业时间等等的法律。所以，正是当她们意识到需要一些政治影响力来摆脱酒类时，女权主义的斗争才真正加速了。但她们不仅仅是为了投票而战。
Frances Willard, for example, was president of the WCTU and a suffragist, but was also instrumental in raising the age of consent, establishing an eight-hour workday, and significant prison reform. She presented temperance as a gateway cause for feminists, assuring those who weren't sure women were ready to vote that their vote was, quote, a, weapon of protection from the tyranny of drink. Nice one, Francis. In the 1890s, public opinion around saloon culture was at an all-time low, leading to the founding of the Anti-Saloon League. While earlier movements advised moderation, the ASL focused on, quote, getting rid of alcohol, period, and quickly took on quite a bit of xenophobia, because while prohibition overlaps with women's writes in a really interesting way, it still has the same limitations of every subsequent American feminist movement. It is far too white and it skews Christian. Saloon patrons were
例如，弗朗西斯·威拉德（Frances Willard）是WCTU的主席，也是一位女性参政权论者，但她在提高同意年龄、建立八小时工作制和重大监狱改革方面也发挥了重要作用。她将节制运动作为女权主义者的入门事业，向那些不确定女性是否准备好投票的人保证，她们的选票是“一种保护自己免受酒类暴政侵害的武器”。干得好，弗朗西斯。在1890年代，围绕酒吧文化的公众舆论处于历史最低点，导致了“反酒吧联盟”（Anti-Saloon League）的成立。虽然早期的运动主张节制，但ASL专注于“彻底摆脱酒精”，并很快带上了相当多的仇外心理，因为虽然禁酒令与女性权利以一种非常有趣的方式重叠，但它仍然具有随后每一场美国女权运动的局限性。它太白了，而且偏向基督教。酒吧常客
overwhelmingly working class and the working class was overwhelmingly underpaid European immigrants. And the booze they were drinking was overwhelmingly German. Do you see where this is going? Regardless of the progressive coalition behind them at the start, Prohibition became a pretty Protestant waspy cause by the early 1900s. Immigrant communities, many of whom came from cultures that alcohol was an integral part of, were never in favor of outlawing booze and did not agree that temperance was the natural state of humanity. And frankly, they're right. There are zero seconds of recorded human history that would lead you to believe that people
绝大多数是工人阶级，而工人阶级绝大多数是薪水过低的欧洲移民。他们喝的酒绝大多数是德国产的。你明白这是什么意思吗？尽管起初背后有进步联盟，但到1900年代初，禁酒令变成了一个相当新教、盎格鲁-撒克逊白人（WASP）的事业。移民社区，其中许多人来自酒精是其文化不可或缺的一部分的背景，从未赞成取缔酒类，也不认为节制是人类的自然状态。坦率地说，他们是对的。在人类记录的历史中，没有一秒钟会让你相信人们
don't love using drugs of virtually any kind. And after years of back and forth between the wets and the dries, yes, those are how the sides self-identified. The Dry Coalition won out. And on January 17, 1920, they toasted with a nice glass of lukewarm water probably as the 18th Amendment was passed in the United States, prohibiting the manufacturer's sale or transportation of intoxication. intoxicating liquors for beverage purposes within the U.S. And less than eight months after that, women got the vote. In the immediate aftermath of prohibition passing, drinking did go down in the U.S. by about a third, according to sexual dynamo Ken Burns.
不喜欢使用几乎任何种类的毒品。在“湿派”和“干派”——是的，这就是双方的自我认同——经过多年的反复较量后，干派联盟赢了。1920年1月17日，他们可能用一杯温水干杯，因为美国通过了第18修正案，禁止在美国境内为饮料目的制造、销售或运输令人陶醉的酒类。在那之后不到八个月，女性获得了投票权。据性学专家肯·伯恩斯称，在禁酒令通过后的直接后果中，美国的饮酒量确实下降了约三分之一。
Saloons were closed and alcohol-related deaths decreased. And there are certain states where the drinking culture remain tempered for decades to come. But in big American cities, people weren't putting the bottle down that easily. Almost immediately, a black market developed around what would become the new saloon, the sexy little setting of all those movies, the speakeasy, and the crooked attempts to enforce prohibition with a fleet of frequently corrupt dry agents using the Volstead Act. And at the very top of this effort was, for a moment in time, the most powerful woman in the American government.
酒吧关闭了，与酒精相关的死亡人数减少了。在某些州，饮酒文化在未来几十年里保持了节制。但在美国大城市，人们并没有那么容易放下酒瓶。几乎立刻，围绕着将成为新酒吧的东西——那些电影中所有那些性感的小场景，地下酒吧——出现了一个黑市，以及使用《沃尔斯泰德法》、拥有一支经常腐败的干派特工队伍来强制执行禁酒令的歪门邪道。在这一努力的最顶端，有一段时间，是美国政府中最有权势的女性。
All of a sudden there's a woman, Mabel Walker Willa Brand, who is this young lawyer who was the head of enforcing prohibition during the jazz age. Miss Mabel Willabrandt was 32 when she was appointed U.S. assistant attorney after an early career shaped by fighting for women convicted and punished for doing sex work. Overnight, she became an extremely powerful force in the U.S. government and was given the massive. massive, unpleasant task of enforcing the ban on alcohol. It was an impossible job, impossible to do. Prohibition was impossible to enforce. So, of course, they gave it to a woman. So women never did vote as a block from the get-go.
突然间，出现了一位女性，梅布尔·沃克·威拉布兰特（Mabel Walker Willebrandt），她是一位年轻的律师，在爵士时代负责执行禁酒令。梅布尔·威拉布兰特小姐在被任命为美国助理司法部长时才32岁，她早期的职业生涯是由为因从事性工作而被定罪和惩罚的女性辩护而塑造的。一夜之间，她成为了美国政府中一股极其强大的力量，并被赋予了执行禁酒令这一巨大、令人不快的任务。这是一项不可能完成的工作，不可能完成。禁酒令是不可能执行的。所以，当然，他们把它交给了一个女人。所以女性从一开始就从未作为一个整体投票。
But the men thought that they were going to vote this block, and they figured they had to have some women in power so that all the women would be excited because the Republicans had given a big job to this woman. And so they were looking for a woman, And she fit the bill. So that's how she got the job. Mabel and the Dries were up against a nation hell-bent on drinking.
但男人们认为她们会作为一个整体投票，他们认为必须让一些女性掌权，这样所有的女性都会感到兴奋，因为共和党人给了这个女人一份重要的工作。所以他们一直在寻找一个女人，而她符合要求。这就是她得到这份工作的原因。梅布尔和干派面对的是一个一心想喝酒的国家。
The people who did continue to drink during prohibition tended to really commit. And now had this rebellious, politicized reason to continue to drink. And quickly, gangs of working-class men became central figures in illegal alcohol sale and consumption in larger cities. And it's here where a lot of the people. similarities with the failed war on drugs crops up. Because alcohol is illegal to sell, and people will seek it out either way, the alcohol that is sold illegally goes through no quality check and can be cut with any number of dangerous ingredients. So today, that's cutting cocaine with fentanyl. During prohibition, this meant cutting booze with ingredients found in paint thinner,
在禁酒令期间继续喝酒的人往往真的投入其中。现在有了这种反叛的、政治化的理由继续喝酒。很快，工人阶级男性的帮派成为了大城市非法酒精销售和消费的核心人物。在这里，许多人与失败的“毒品战争”的相似之处浮现出来。因为酒精是非法销售的，而且人们无论如何都会去寻找它，所以非法销售的酒精不经过任何质量检查，可以掺入任何数量的危险成分。所以今天，这就是在可卡因中掺入芬太尼。在禁酒令期间，这意味着在酒中掺入油漆稀释剂中的成分，
which resulted in thousands becoming blind or even dying. So people who drank were not just being criminalized by the government, they were more at risk than ever. Which makes it interesting that we don't really teach prohibition in schools, and even more interesting that these parallels with the war on drugs never seem to come up. I'm adjusting my tinfoil hat. Okay, by the mid-1920s, cracks had already begun to show as the supporters of the dry side added some rather scary people to their ranks. While Prohibition was initially championed by feminists, abolitionists, and the KKK leader came out in strong favor of prohibition policies, using the issue as a recruitment tool for cleaning up the neighborhood by implicating that anyone who didn't align with white
导致成千上万的人失明甚至死亡。所以喝酒的人不仅被政府定罪，而且比以往任何时候都更危险。这使得我们不在学校里真正教授禁酒令，以及这些与毒品战争的相似之处似乎从未被提及，变得更加有趣。我正在调整我的锡纸帽。好吧，到了1920年代中期，随着干派的支持者将一些相当可怕的人加入到他们的行列中，裂痕已经开始显现。虽然禁酒令最初受到女权主义者、废奴主义者的拥护，但三K党领袖公开强烈支持禁酒政策，利用这个问题作为清理社区的招募工具，暗示任何不与白人
Protestant nationalism was more likely to be a violent alcoholic. That is, black Americans, Catholics, Jews, and immigrants. Meanwhile, the speakeasy held potential to be a more progressive space than the saloon. Some speakeasies, not all, were racially integrated decades before Jim Crow loss ended. And it was there that jazz music and vaudeville acts could really flourish, where women could explore newfound sexual freedom. Quick sidebar here because it is so funny to me, there's this historian in the Ken Burns documentary who states confidently that it is during this sexual revolution of the 1920s that men discovered the clitoris, which is certainly a claim. He gives no sources. Mabel Willa Brandt worked hard to frighten the
新教民族主义保持一致的人更有可能是暴力的酒鬼。也就是说，黑人、天主教徒、犹太人和移民。与此同时，地下酒吧有潜力成为比酒吧更进步的空间。一些地下酒吧，并非全部，在吉姆·克劳法（Jim Crow laws）结束前几十年就实现了种族融合。正是在那里，爵士乐和杂耍表演才能真正蓬勃发展，女性可以在那里探索新发现的性自由。这里插一句，因为我觉得太搞笑了，肯·伯恩斯纪录片里有一位历史学家自信地声称，正是在1920年代的这场性革命中，男人们发现了阴蒂，这当然是一个说法。他没有给出任何来源。梅布尔·威拉布兰特努力恐吓
speakeasy operators of New York and Chicago with little success, but the anti-saloon League had considerable political influence throughout the 20s and even helped get a dry candidate elected president in 1928 in the form of Herbert Hoover. Although it's worth saying, Herbert Hoover did drink. Imagine a politician being a hypocrite. In classic American fashion, the Drys ignored the working class, immigrants, and any non-Protestant as they tend to to this day. But in another interesting twist, one of the first people that Drys seemed to take seriously as a threat to prohibition was kind of one of them, a wealthy white Republican woman. The Jazz Age opened up the whole world of drinking to women who didn't.
纽约和芝加哥的地下酒吧经营者，但收效甚微，但反酒吧联盟在整个20年代拥有相当大的政治影响力，甚至在1928年帮助赫伯特·胡佛（Herbert Hoover）当选为干派总统。尽管值得一提的是，赫伯特·胡佛确实喝酒。想象一下政客是个伪君子。以典型的美国方式，干派忽视了工人阶级、移民和任何非新教徒，就像他们至今所做的那样。但在另一个有趣的转折中，干派似乎认真对待的第一个威胁禁酒令的人之一，竟然是他们自己人，一位富有的白人共和党女性。爵士时代为那些以前不喝酒的女性打开了整个饮酒世界，
drink before, and sexual freedom and smoking and all of this behavior that was considered naughty before suddenly becomes very cool. And also those suffrage leaders and the leaders of the temperance movement were getting old. And now they were these old fogies, you know, and they were like the opposite of the glamorous, youthful, fun-loving flapper. And so nobody wanted to follow them anymore, and that coincides with the rise of Pauline Sabin. Pauline Sabin was the heiress to the Morton-Salt fortune, and she started one of the most effective anti-prohibition organizations in the country, an organization exclusively made up of women. She became convinced that prohibition had to be repealed, and there had been several organizations
性自由、吸烟以及所有那些以前被认为是淘气的行为，突然变得非常酷。而且那些参政权领袖和节制运动的领袖们正在变老。现在她们成了这些老古板，你知道，她们就像是迷人、年轻、热爱享乐的摩登女郎的对立面。所以没人想再追随她们了，这与宝琳·萨宾（Pauline Sabin）的崛起不谋而合。宝琳·萨宾是莫顿盐业（Morton-Salt）财富的继承人，她发起了全国最有效的反禁酒令组织之一，一个完全由女性组成的组织。她确信禁酒令必须被废除，并且之前已经有几个由男性领导的反对禁酒令的组织，
run by men who had been against prohibition, but they were in effect. They never got anywhere. And so Pauline literally goes, hold my beer, finds a bunch of like-minded women, and starts organizing as a one-issue activist to end prohibition. The organization that she started was a woman's organization which embraced women from all walks of life and even all races. She herself was very wealthy. She had a lot of wealthy friends.
但它们毫无作用。它们从未取得任何进展。所以宝琳真的说，帮我拿一下啤酒，找到了一群志同道合的女性，并开始以单一议题活动家的身份组织起来，以结束禁酒令。她发起的组织是一个妇女组织，它接纳了来自各行各业甚至所有种族的女性。她本人非常富有。她有很多富有的朋友。
And they funded it and they made it into something really big. and forceful that the women's Christian temperance union couldn't compete with. And they always came out ahead. She fit into this idea of what a modern woman should be, which was glamorous and youthful. By 1929, the writing was on the wall. Between the Valentine's Day massacre in Chicago and the stock market crash, it was obvious that prohibition and the legislation of morality had not improved things. And everyone wanted a drink.
她们资助了它，并把它变成了一个非常大、非常有力的组织，妇女基督教节制联盟无法与之竞争。她们总是处于领先地位。她符合现代女性应该是什么样子的想法，那就是迷人且年轻。到1929年，大势已去。在芝加哥情人节大屠杀和股市崩盘之间，很明显，禁酒令和道德立法并没有改善情况。每个人都想喝一杯。
In the next election, Republican Pauline Sabin, endorsed Democrat Franklin D. Roosevelt because FDR promised to undo prohibition, stating that his goals were to reorganize the banks, cut federal spending, and legalize 3.2 beer. And so it was. In no small part because of Sabin's organizing, on April 7, 1933, Americans could legally buy beer again after nearly 14 years of prohibition. By the end of that year, the 21st Amendment repealed the 18th, the only time that's happened in American history. So class, did prohibition work? Most historians will give you a hard no.
在下一次选举中，共和党人宝琳·萨宾支持了民主党人富兰克林·D·罗斯福（FDR），因为FDR承诺废除禁酒令，称他的目标是重组银行、削减联邦开支并使3.2%的啤酒合法化。事实也确实如此。在很大程度上由于萨宾的组织工作，1933年4月7日，美国人在经历了近14年的禁酒令后，可以再次合法购买啤酒。那年年底，第21修正案废除了第18修正案，这是美国历史上唯一一次发生这种情况。那么同学们，禁酒令起作用了吗？大多数历史学家会给你一个坚定的否定回答。
It treated a symptom of American society, that being excessive drinking instead of the disease, the poor work and economic conditions, the disregard for any culture that wasn't Protestant, and the reality that parties are fun. legislating morality just does not work. It never has. But I'm going to argue something a little grayer than that, because that's all true. And Prohibition did permanently change Americans' drinking habits. With the exception of a brief window in the early 1980s,
它治疗的是美国社会的一种症状，即过度饮酒，而不是疾病本身，即糟糕的工作和经济条件、对任何非新教文化的漠视，以及聚会很有趣这一事实。立法道德根本行不通。从来没有行通过。但我打算提出一个比这更灰色的观点，因为那都是事实。而且禁酒令确实永久地改变了美国人的饮酒习惯。除了1980年代初的一小段时间外，
Americans' drinking habits have rarely returned to pre-prohibition levels. And the fight for and against Prohibition did open up a lot of avenues to power that hadn't existed prior for women specifically. So by the end of 1933, alcohol was legal again, and America's relationship to it was weirder than ever. Because remember, a huge number of Americans drank their way through prohibition. So when the government stopped trying to ban alcohol, they were sort of just handing the problem back to the individual. Well, we tried. You're on your own. No meaningful public program replaced prohibition. And so two years later, a program created by problem drinkers for problem drinkers starts to take shape,
美国人的饮酒习惯很少回到禁酒令前的水平。而且支持和反对禁酒令的斗争确实为女性专门开辟了许多以前不存在的权力途径。所以到1933年底，酒精再次合法化，而美国与它的关系比以往任何时候都更奇怪。因为记住，大量美国人在禁酒令期间一直喝着酒。所以当政府停止试图禁止酒精时，他们实际上只是把问题交还给了个人。好吧，我们试过了。你自己看着办吧。没有任何有意义的公共项目取代禁酒令。所以两年后，一个由酗酒者为酗酒者创建的项目开始成形，
one that advocated for a kind of private personal prohibition as the only way out of alcoholism. Not moderation or reducing your drinking, but banning it from your life entirely while submitting yourself to a higher power. And hey, sometimes you get this cool little chip to prove it. Their movement was called Alcoholics Anonymous, and it wouldn't. It wouldn't be long before AA would change the way the country thought about addiction. Okay, so I'm standing outside this kind of VFW-like hall with that little white chip in my hand. And now that I think about it, it's a poker chip, so probably wouldn't fly in gamblers anonymous. Anyway, I was kind of surprised to find it there.
它主张一种私人的、个人的禁酒作为摆脱酗酒的唯一途径。不是节制或减少饮酒，而是将其从你的生活中彻底禁止，同时将自己臣服于一种更高的力量。嘿，有时你会得到这个很酷的小筹码来证明这一点。他们的运动被称为匿名戒酒互助会，用不了多久，AA就会改变这个国家对成瘾的看法。好吧，所以我站在这个类似退伍军人协会（VFW）的大厅外面，手里拿着那个白色的小筹码。现在我想起来了，这是一个扑克筹码，所以可能在“匿名赌徒互助会”里行不通。总之，我有点惊讶在那里发现了它。
My relationship with alcohol was and is pretty dysregulated. Like most comedians, it's not unusual to be paid and drink tickets when you're working. new material out, and the habit escalated during the lockdown and solidified into a near-daily ritual during the years my dad was sick. So it hadn't ruined my life, but it had become very present, and it did not feel good. But what I didn't want, in spite of AA, saving my dad's life, was to go to a meeting myself, because I'd heard there was a lot of God, a lot of black and white thinking. Not to mention that the social aspect of AA kind of reminded me of the social anxiety that contributed to my own drinking in the first place. As I understood it, a sip of anything would render
我和酒精的关系过去和现在都相当失调。像大多数喜剧演员一样，当你创作新素材时，用酒券支付报酬并不罕见，这种习惯在封锁期间升级，并在我爸爸生病的那些年里固化为一种近乎日常的仪式。所以它没有毁掉我的生活，但它变得非常明显，而且感觉并不好。但我不想做的是，尽管AA救了我爸爸的命，我自己去参加会议，因为我听说那里有很多上帝，很多非黑即白的思维。更不用说AA的社交方面让我想起了导致我最初饮酒的社交焦虑。据我理解，喝任何东西的一小口都会让
that little white chip meaningless. It meant a failure, a slip. And my image of AA was a lot of guys that looked like my dad, telling the same story that my dad told. It puts me at this crossroad I found myself at over and over, because I know for a fact that for many people, AA is a life-changing force and that those who AA has worked for can get a little swiftly about it, and that AA does not work for everyone. It is not a safe or productive environment for everyone, and that I don't think it's fair to position a sobriety attempt as a failure because the most popular system was not effective. But here's the thing with AA. Chances are, right now, there is a free meeting down the street from you in about 20 minutes. And that's something that no program outside of the church
那枚白色小筹码变得毫无意义。这意味着失败，一次滑倒。我对AA的印象是很多像我爸爸那样的家伙，讲述着和我爸爸讲的一样的故事。这让我处于一个我一次又一次发现自己所处的十字路口，因为我确实知道，对许多人来说，AA是一种改变生活的力量，那些AA对之有效的人可能会对此有点沾沾自喜，而且AA并不对每个人都有效。它对每个人来说都不是一个安全或富有成效的环境，而且我不认为将戒酒尝试定位为失败是公平的，仅仅因为最流行的系统并不有效。但关于AA，这里有一点：很有可能，现在，离你几条街外大约20分钟内就有一个免费的会议。这是除了教会之外没有任何项目
itself can claim. So how did we get to the place where this incredibly specific, imperfect program was the option? Let's go back to 1935. It's two years after prohibition was repealed, and if you were a Problem drinker, babe, that's none of the government's business anymore. You're on your own. Which left a lot of people at a loss of where they could turn. As the story goes, we're in Akron, Ohio at the Mayflower Hotel, and a 39-year-old man named Bill Wilson, Bill W in A. in A.A. Cannon, is in town for a business trip after flopping out of Wall Street and law school because of his drinking. And he's feeling very tempted to go to the bar. But instead of giving in, he calls the nearest.
本身可以声称的。那么我们是如何走到这个极其具体、不完美的项目成为选择的地步的呢？让我们回到1935年。那是禁酒令废除两年后，如果你是一个酗酒者，宝贝，那不再是政府的事了。你自己看着办。这让许多人不知道该转向哪里。故事是这样的，我们在俄亥俄州阿克伦市的五月花酒店，一个名叫比尔·威尔逊（Bill Wilson）的39岁男子，AA教义中的比尔·W，因为喝酒而在华尔街和法学院失败后，正在城里出差。他感到非常想去酒吧。但与其屈服，他给最近的
church and asks them if he can get in touch with other people trying to maintain sobriety so that he can vent and stay accountable. Eventually, he gets connected with Robert Smith, Dr. Bob in the AAEU, and Dr. Bob is also trying to stay sober in a post-prohibition world. He'd taken advantage of the 18th Amendment loophole that allowed doctors like himself to prescribe alcohol. And Dr. Bob and Bill W. sat in a mutual friends living room. for five hours, just drinking coffee and talking. They found it really helpful. And a month later, A.A. was officially in motion.
教会打电话，问他们是否可以联系其他试图保持清醒的人，这样他就可以发泄并保持负责。最终，他与罗伯特·史密斯（Robert Smith）取得了联系，即AA中的鲍勃医生（Dr. Bob），鲍勃医生也试图在禁酒令后的世界里保持清醒。他利用了第18修正案的漏洞，允许像他这样的医生开酒精处方。鲍勃医生和比尔·W坐在一位共同朋友的客厅里，喝了五个小时的咖啡，一直在聊天。他们发现这真的很有帮助。一个月后，AA正式启动了。
The first few years of the group were called A.A.'s Flying Blind era. So no 12 steps yet, none of the traditions we associate with the program today. It was just a bunch of alcoholics trying to stay sober by sticking together and having community. It's interesting to point out that this is both very similar to the Washington and both Bill W. and Dr. Bob insist they had never heard of the group. But what they were familiar with was a Christian movement called the Oxford Group, which wasn't about alcoholism at all, but did focus on living a more pure Christian life. And this extended to sobriety. And you can see the influence of the Oxford Group in what eventually becomes the principles of AA. They were an
该小组最初的几年被称为AA的“盲目飞行”时代。所以还没有12个步骤，也没有我们今天与该项目联系在一起的传统。这只是一群试图通过团结在一起和拥有社区来保持清醒的酗酒者。有趣的是，这与华盛顿人协会非常相似，比尔·W和鲍勃医生都坚持说他们从未听说过那个团体。但他们熟悉的是一个名为“牛津小组”（Oxford Group）的基督教运动，它根本不是关于酗酒的，但确实专注于过一种更纯粹的基督徒生活。这延伸到了清醒。你可以在最终成为AA原则的内容中看到牛津小组的影响。他们是一个
anonymous group. They used the confession-like practice of sharing. They had to be a. They had had tenets that functioned similar to steps, and they upheld the concept of surrendering over to God's plan while maintaining that they were not a religion. They're just a spiritual group, guys. They just happened to mention God, Jesus, and Christianity across their literature. Moving on, Bill W. and Dr. Bob took these ideas and applied them to alcoholism specifically, developing over the next few years what would become the core tenets of Alcoholics Anonymous and its 12-step program. We don't have time for them all, but here's some relevant highlights. This was a program of complete, unwavering abstinence, that alcoholics generally hit bottom or admitted we were powerless over alcohol.
匿名团体。他们使用类似忏悔的分享练习。他们必须是。他们有类似于步骤的信条，他们坚持将自己臣服于上帝计划的概念，同时坚持他们不是一个宗教。伙计们，他们只是一个精神团体。他们只是碰巧在他们的文献中提到了上帝、耶稣和基督教。继续，比尔·W和鲍勃医生将这些想法应用到酗酒问题上，在接下来的几年里发展出了后来成为匿名戒酒互助会及其12步计划的核心信条。我们没有时间讲完所有这些，但这里有一些相关的重点。这是一个完全、坚定不移的戒酒计划，酗酒者通常跌入谷底或承认我们对酒精无能为力。
There would be no centralized leadership, and all branches of AA would be self-run and self-funded by their members. that members should connect with a sponsor, which is another recovering alcoholic with more sobriety time, to serve as a sort of spiritual advisor. That the group viewed alcoholism as a progressive disease, and that alcoholics may have an allergy to the substance. And finally, that recovery was a lifelong process, and there was no such thing as a full cure to alcoholism. They eventually settled on the name Alcoholics Anonymous. Some members were calling it the 100 Men Corporation. And by all accounts, most early members of AA were white guys like the founders. And the alcoholic recovery process was developed with them in mind specifically.
没有集中的领导，AA的所有分支机构都将由其成员自行管理和资助。成员应该与赞助人联系，这是另一位有更多戒酒时间的康复酗酒者，作为一种精神顾问。该小组将酗酒视为一种进行性疾病，酗酒者可能对这种物质过敏。最后，康复是一个终身的过程，没有所谓的酗酒完全治愈。他们最终确定了“匿名戒酒互助会”这个名字。一些成员称它为“100人公司”。据所有报道，AA的大多数早期成员都是像创始人那样的白人男性。而酗酒康复过程是专门为他们制定的。
So they weren't saying no girls in gays, but it is heavily implied in the way that their core text is written. Their core text is called Alcoholics. anonymous. It was first published in 1939, has been revised several times, and has since sold over 37 million copies. By members, it is often referred to as The Big Book. And you can see exactly how the founders thought about women in that first 1939 edition of the Big Book, where all of A.A.'s tenets are laid out. After seven chapters that cover the founder's stories, the disease model of addiction, and agnosticism, the eighth chapter is entitled to wives. Buckle in. If he gets the sense that you were a nag or a killjoy, your chance of accomplishing anything useful may be zero. Say you do
所以他们并没有说不准女性和同性恋者参加，但在他们核心文本的写作方式中强烈暗示了这一点。他们的核心文本被称为《匿名戒酒互助会》。它于1939年首次出版，经过多次修订，此后已售出超过3700万册。成员们通常称它为《大书》（The Big Book）。你可以在1939年第一版《大书》中准确地看到创始人对比尔·W是如何看待女性的，其中列出了AA的所有信条。在涵盖创始人故事、成瘾疾病模型和不可知论的七章之后，第八章标题为“致妻子们”。系好安全带。如果他感觉到你是一个唠叨鬼或扫兴的人，你完成任何有用的事情的机会可能是零。说你
not want to be a wet blanket, that you only want him to take care of his health. If you cooperate rather than complain, you will find his excess enthusiasm will tone down. This is just scraping the surface, but you get the feeling. Keep in mind, this original chapter was written by Bill W. A man who would prolifically cheat on his wife, Lois, for the remainder of his one human life, in spite of her unwavering support and co-founding of the Al-Anon program. In fact, Bill W. is probably the most famous example of men in recovery praying on women in recovery, to the point that his behavior has a shorthand in AA to this day.
不想成为一个扫兴的人，你只是希望他照顾好自己的健康。如果你合作而不是抱怨，你会发现他过度的热情会减弱。这只是触及了表面，但你明白了那种感觉。请记住，这一原始章节是由比尔·W撰写的。一个在他余下的一生中会频繁背叛他的妻子洛伊丝（Lois）的男人，尽管她给予了他坚定不移的支持并共同创立了Al-Anon项目。事实上，比尔·W可能是康复中的男性掠夺康复中的女性最著名的例子，以至于他的行为在AA中至今都有一个简写。
13th stepping. It's basically a cheeky way to say that there is a pattern across A.A.'s history of elder members sexually praying on newly sober converts, almost always men praying on women, and in Bill W's case, required A.A. to enforce a quote-unquote founder's watch to make sure that his sexual impropriety did not tarnish A.A.'s reputation. Feeling safe? I sure am. What I find really revealing about this chapter, is not just that it's misogynist, it's that it casts women in the same role as in prohibition.
“13th stepping”。这基本上是一种厚颜无耻的说法，意指匿名戒酒互助会（A.A.）历史上存在一种模式：资深成员对刚戒酒的新人进行性掠夺，几乎总是男性对女性下手。在比尔·W（Bill W.）的案例中，这甚至需要A.A.强制执行所谓的“创始人观察”，以确保他的性不端行为不会玷污A.A.的声誉。感到安全了吗？我确实感到很安全。关于这一章，我发现真正发人深省的不仅是它的厌女症，还在于它将女性置于与禁酒令时期相同的角色中。
It is assumed that women are the victims of alcoholics, the emotional support system and caretakers for alcoholics, and not alcoholics themselves. Around the time the big book was published, A.A's popularity started exploding, particularly after a big article in the Saturday Evening Post in 1941. called Alcoholics Anonymous, freed slaves of drink, now they free others. At the time of this article, there were about 2,000 members in AA, and within two weeks, the office had received nearly 1,000 requests for more information. Within a year, membership quadrupled.
人们认为女性是酗酒者的受害者、酗酒者的情感支持系统和照料者，而不是酗酒者本身。在《大书》（Big Book）出版前后，A.A.的知名度开始爆炸式增长，特别是在1941年《星期六晚邮报》刊登了一篇题为《匿名戒酒互助会：从酒精的奴隶中解放出来，现在他们解放了他人》的大型文章之后。在那篇文章发表时，A.A.大约有2000名成员，而在两周内，办公室就收到了近1000份咨询信息。一年之内，会员人数翻了两番。
Within a decade, AA had over 100,000 members. And since no alternative group was growing on this scale, people who felt othered by AA's foundational principles, and if Chapter 8 for wives is any indication, that would be over half the country, they would have to find or create a space for themselves within AA. But women who tried to join AA groups early on were often blocked by members or their wives. They were accused of coming to AA to get dates, or were seen as a promiscuous threat to men's sobriety, which is confusing in so many ways. Like, the logic is, hey, baby, want to see a woman at her absolute lowest? I get a life. And as women continued to try to join AA, there was a lot of internal resistance. There's an article in
十年内，A.A.拥有了超过10万名成员。由于没有其他替代组织能达到这种规模，那些对A.A.基本原则感到格格不入的人——如果“给妻子们的一章”（Chapter 8 for wives）有什么暗示的话，那将是全国一半以上的人口——他们必须在A.A.内部寻找或创造属于自己的空间。但早期试图加入A.A.小组的女性经常受到成员或其妻子的阻挠。她们被指责加入A.A.是为了约会，或者被视为对男性戒酒的滥交威胁，这在很多方面都令人困惑。就像，逻辑是这样的：嘿，宝贝，想看一个女人处于绝对低谷的样子吗？我有病吧。随着女性继续尝试加入A.A.，内部存在很大的阻力。有一篇文章在
the AA journal. It's called The Grapevine. It's published to this day from 1946 that I think illustrates this point really well. The opening sentence, which is written by a conveniently anonymous author says, Now that women form an increasing membership in Alcoholics Anonymous, there seems to be a general feeling that they not only have a specialized problem, but like the purple cow we'd rather see, they are one. Oh, this absolute murderer's row of lazy misogynist talking points is used to explain why this writer believes most women drop out of AA,
A.A.的期刊《葡萄藤》（The Grapevine）上。它至今仍在出版，发表于1946年，我认为它很好地说明了这一点。开篇第一句由一位方便地匿名的作者写道：“现在女性在匿名戒酒互助会中的成员比例越来越高，人们普遍感到她们不仅有一个特殊的问题，而且就像我们宁愿看到的紫色奶牛一样，她们本身就是一种特殊的存在。”哦，这一连串懒惰的厌女症论点被用来解释为什么这位作者认为大多数女性会退出A.A.，
refusing to consider alternatives, like the 12th system may not be effective, for everybody, or, and I'm just taking a shot in the dark here, maybe women were uncomfortable around people like this freak who was roasting them in the organization's newsletter. Still, they kept trying. But one woman in particular, Marty Man, managed to stick it out. Marty is often referred to as the first woman to achieve long-term sobriety in AA, and she would ultimately become one of the organization's most public faces, essentially working. as a lobbyist for the group, something she took a lot of criticism for, because by speaking publicly about her experience, she was breaking the fundamental tenet of anonymity.
拒绝考虑其他选择，比如第12步系统可能并不对每个人都有效，或者——我只是随口一说——也许女性在组织通讯中被这个嘲讽她们的怪胎周围感到不舒服。尽管如此，她们还是不断尝试。但其中一位女性，马蒂·曼（Marty Mann），设法坚持了下来。马蒂通常被称为A.A.中第一位实现长期戒酒的女性，她最终成为了该组织最公开的面孔之一，本质上是作为该组织的游说者，这让她受到了很多批评，因为通过公开谈论自己的经历，她打破了匿名这一基本原则。
And while this wasn't spoken about at the time, she was also an early prominent queer member of AA. Marty was a lesbian who hung out with Virginia Woolf and Gertrude Stein, and it's because of her that women are finally acknowledged as alcoholics as well in the second edition of the big book, in which Marty Mann writes a chapter entitled, Women, suffer too. Boy, do they. But thanks to Marty, the book acknowledges that the two wives chapter is outdated, that women can be alcoholics too. But regardless, two wives remains in the big book to this day. Just take it out, fellas, it's not Psalms. And of the many contributions women have made to AA over the years, it turns out the chip itself may have originated with a nun. I was actually surprised to
虽然当时没有公开谈论，但她也是A.A.早期著名的酷儿成员。马蒂是一位女同性恋者，曾与弗吉尼亚·伍尔夫（Virginia Woolf）和格特鲁德·斯泰因（Gertrude Stein）交往。正是因为她，女性在《大书》第二版中终于被承认为酗酒者，马蒂·曼在书中写了一章，题为《女性也受苦》。天哪，她们确实受苦。但多亏了马蒂，这本书承认了“给妻子们的一章”已经过时，女性也可能是酗酒者。但无论如何，“给妻子们”这一章至今仍保留在《大书》中。伙计们，把它删掉吧，它又不是《诗篇》。在女性多年来为A.A.做出的众多贡献中，事实证明，筹码本身可能起源于一位修女。我实际上很惊讶地
learn that sobriety chips, something that I felt was so central to the program, isn't actually official A-A-Canon nor a part of its official history. Chips are basically a local custom that began in the 1940s and are often credited to a nun named Sister Ignatia, who worked with Dr. Bob at a hospital where alcoholics would dry out. When the patients were released, she would give them a sacred heart medallion, which she asked them to return before they took their first drink. There are other versions of this story, but this one sticks out to me because it so clearly strikes on how present both women and religion were at a foundational level of AA, even if their texts and history resist that reading. Just as in the prohibition era, a complicated
了解到戒酒筹码——我觉得这是该计划的核心——实际上并不是A.A.的官方准则，也不是其官方历史的一部分。筹码基本上是20世纪40年代开始的一种地方习俗，通常归功于一位名叫伊格纳蒂亚修女（Sister Ignatia）的修女，她在一家医院与鲍勃医生（Dr. Bob）一起工作，酗酒者在那里戒酒。当病人出院时，她会给他们一枚圣心奖章，并要求他们在喝第一杯酒之前归还。这个故事还有其他版本，但这个版本让我印象深刻，因为它非常清楚地表明了女性和宗教在A.A.的基础层面是多么普遍，即使它们的文本和历史拒绝这种解读。正如在禁酒令时代一样，一个复杂的
array of women are moving the cause forward and are all but erased by history as it's presented today. And of course, the ways in which people have been othered in pursuit of those chips doesn't stop with gender. It's anyone who isn't a white Christian man, which is still true today. The numbers bear this out. In 2022, AA membership was largely concentrated in America and Canada was nearly 88% white and about two-thirds men. And you don't need me to tell you that this does not square with the respective populations in these countries. And my theory is the reason that this is is very much baked into American history at the time of AA's founding, which has given it a stink that is very hard to get rid of.
女性群体正在推动事业向前发展，但在今天呈现的历史中几乎被抹去了。当然，人们在追求这些筹码的过程中被排斥的方式并不仅限于性别。它是任何非白人基督徒男性的人，这一点在今天仍然适用。数据证实了这一点。2022年，A.A.的成员主要集中在美国和加拿大，近88%是白人，约三分之二是男性。你不需要我告诉你，这与这些国家的相应人口比例不符。我的理论是，造成这种情况的原因很大程度上植根于A.A.成立时的美国历史，这给它留下了一种很难摆脱的恶臭。
There have been some efforts by AA to welcome black members with various pamphlets and inclusive groups. But remember, this group took off in the early 1940s, long before Jim Crow policies were formally dismantled. While Bill W. is said to have welcomed black alcoholics into meetings as early as 1940, Dr. Bob and other white members objected to this, and black alcoholics were only permitted to attend AA meetings as guests. Bill W. reflected on this in 1984's Pass It On, writing,
A.A.曾做出一些努力，通过各种小册子和包容性小组来欢迎黑人成员。但请记住，这个组织在20世纪40年代初兴起，远在吉姆·克劳法（Jim Crow policies）被正式废除之前。虽然据说比尔·W早在1940年就欢迎黑人酗酒者参加会议，但鲍勃医生和其他白人成员对此表示反对，黑人酗酒者只被允许作为客人参加A.A.会议。比尔·W在1984年的《传递下去》（Pass It On）中对此进行了反思，写道：
Along with you, I feel very deeply about this race business. Save this question, I suppose AA is the most democratic society in the world. All men should have an equal opportunity to recover from alcoholism. That is the shining ideal. but unhappily, it may not be achieved in our lifetime. Black AA meetings became more common over time, but the overall group's racism very much persisted. In 1945, an all-black St. Louis meeting elected not to make it public knowledge
“和你一样，我对种族问题感触很深。撇开这个问题不谈，我认为A.A.是世界上最民主的社会。所有人都应该有平等的机会从酗酒中恢复过来。这是闪耀的理想。但不幸的是，这可能在我们有生之年无法实现。”黑人A.A.会议随着时间的推移变得更加普遍，但整个组织的种族主义依然存在。1945年，圣路易斯的一个全黑人会议选择不公开这一事实，
out of fear of white AA members. In a pamphlet, AA for the black and African-American alcoholic, most anonymous stories have some admission that they assumed the group was only for old white guys and that they did not feel comfortable or welcome. And to be clear, these are not issues that went away. While there are plenty of all-black AA groups that have been extremely helpful for members, as recently as 2021, a black member and writer named Maya Richard Craven wrote about her racial trauma being treated as what is referred to as an outside issue by white members.
出于对白人A.A.成员的恐惧。在一本名为《针对黑人和非裔美国人酗酒者的A.A.》的小册子中，大多数匿名故事都承认他们曾以为该组织只适合老白人，而且他们感到不舒服或不受欢迎。需要明确的是，这些问题并没有消失。虽然有许多全黑人A.A.小组对成员非常有帮助，但就在2021年，一位名叫玛雅·理查德·克雷文（Maya Richard Craven）的黑人成员和作家写道，她的种族创伤被白人成员视为所谓的“外部问题”。
And this harkens back to the Washingtonians, which, as we said before, were thought to have failed as a larger coalition because they, quote-unquote, got political. AA elects not to do this. And so what is being invoked to Richard Craven is a general AA policy to keep politics out of their meeting. And the definition of politics is absolutely stated from a white patriarchal standpoint. This pattern is repeated over and over again, in indigenous communities, in queer communities, and in non-English-speaking communities. It's not for lack of effort internally throughout the years. Today, there are meetings for all of these groups, but it's understandable why people perceive AA as not really being for them. Like so many American inventions,
这让人回想起华盛顿禁酒协会（Washingtonians），正如我们之前所说，他们被认为作为一个更大的联盟失败了，因为他们“搞政治”。A.A.选择不这样做。因此，理查德·克雷文所引用的，是A.A.的一项普遍政策，即让政治远离他们的会议。而政治的定义完全是从白人父权制的立场出发的。这种模式在原住民社区、酷儿社区和非英语社区中反复出现。这并不是因为多年来内部缺乏努力。今天，所有这些群体都有会议，但人们认为A.A.并不真正适合他们是可以理解的。就像许多美国发明一样，
12-step programs have had to be retrofitted for marginalized people, rather than created with them in mind. So for better or worse, not much has changed about AA or 12-step programs, except that they've grown tremendously. Currently, AA is estimated to be somewhere in the 2 million-member range, although the whole anonymous thing does make it difficult to track. And that doesn't account for how influential the 12-step model is and how ingratiated Alcoholics Anonymous has become in American life. Today, nearly 100 years after AA's fan of the world, The Substance Abuse and Mental Health Services Administration estimates that over half of rehab centers in the United States use 12-step curriculums, which means that if you are arrested on a DUI charge and sentenced to 52 weeks of substance abuse treatment by a court,
12步计划必须为边缘化人群进行改造，而不是在设计时考虑到他们。所以无论好坏，A.A.或12步计划并没有太大改变，只是规模扩大了许多。目前，A.A.估计有200万左右的成员，尽管“匿名”这一特性使得追踪变得困难。这还没有考虑到12步模式的影响力有多大，以及匿名戒酒互助会已经多么深入地融入了美国生活。今天，在A.A.风靡世界近100年后，美国药物滥用和心理健康服务管理局估计，美国超过一半的康复中心使用12步课程，这意味着如果你因酒驾被捕，并被法院判处52周的药物滥用治疗，
12-step meetings are going to be the most accessible and chances are affordable option. And the fact that AA is so ubiquitous becomes a bit of a problem when you think about all that God talk I reference. Okay, we have to talk about America and religion. I'm sorry, we do. And I know we do, because while AA has consistently said it is not a religion, courts have found going back to the 1990s that a judge cannot sentence someone to going to AA meetings specifically, because to do so would be unconstitutional under the First Amendment, specifically with regards to freedom of religion. But even so, A.A.'s own records indicate that around 150,000 people attending meetings each year are doing so to address a court order, not necessarily of their own volition, which is a common criticism coming from those advocating for alternatives to A.A. And if you're collecting chips, I think it's important to be honest about this religious aspect.
12步会议将是最容易获得且很可能负担得起的选择。当你想到我提到的所有关于上帝的谈话时，A.A.无处不在的事实就成了一个问题。好吧，我们必须谈谈美国和宗教。抱歉，我们必须谈。我知道我们必须谈，因为虽然A.A.一直声称它不是一种宗教，但法院早在20世纪90年代就裁定，法官不能专门判处某人参加A.A.会议，因为这样做根据第一修正案是违宪的，特别是在宗教自由方面。但即便如此，A.A.自己的记录显示，每年约有15万名参加会议的人是为了应对法院命令，而不一定是出于自愿，这是那些主张A.A.替代方案的人常见的批评。如果你在收集筹码，我认为诚实地面对这个宗教方面很重要。
Alcoholics Anonymous has consistently claimed they are not a religion, but their second step is, we came to believe that. that a power greater than ourselves could restore us to sanity. Okay, don't yell at me, but it's sounding a little religious. No, okay, let's go to the third step. Made a decision to turn our will and our lives over to the care of God as we understood him. You guys. What's the fourth step? Made a searching and fearless moral inventory of ourselves.
匿名戒酒互助会一直声称他们不是一种宗教，但他们的第二步是：“我们开始相信……一种比我们自身更强大的力量可以使我们恢复理智。”好吧，别对我大喊大叫，但这听起来有点宗教色彩。不，好吧，让我们看看第三步。“决定将我们的意志和我们的生活托付给我们所理解的上帝的照顾。”伙计们。第四步是什么？“对自己进行了一次彻底而无畏的道德盘点。”
Okay, I like this one. Moral, maybe a little loaded, but it kind of sounds like therapy. Okay, fifth step. Admit it to God, to ourselves, and to another human being, the exact nature of our wrongs. Guys, it's a religion. Come on. God, higher power, and prayer are mentioned in half of the 12 steps, and a form of spiritual surrender is referenced in all but four, two steps that involved taking that searching in fearless moral inventory, and two steps that concern making amends with people a member is harmed while actively drinking. The big book itself functions, as a religious text, down to the number of AA meetings that center around it, similar to a Bible study.
好吧，我喜欢这一步。道德，可能有点沉重，但听起来有点像心理治疗。好吧，第五步。“向上帝、向我们自己和另一个人承认我们错误的本质。”伙计们，这就是宗教。得了吧。上帝、更高的力量和祈祷在12个步骤中有一半被提及，除了四个步骤外，所有步骤都提到了某种形式的精神投降——其中两个步骤涉及进行那种彻底而无畏的道德盘点，另外两个步骤涉及与成员在积极饮酒时伤害过的人进行弥补。《大书》本身的功能就像一本宗教文本，甚至连围绕它展开的A.A.会议数量也类似于圣经学习。
But the program talks their way around its clear similarities to Christianity in an interesting way. A.A. says it's a spiritual organization that is welcoming of an individual's conception of a higher power, the care of God as we understood him, as the third step says. There's plenty of AA literature that explains that this is what makes the organization, accessible to a person of any faith, including atheists and agnostics. There are secular branches of AA, but that doesn't change that AA is an organization that's rooted in Christianity, in its literature, and how it thinks. To state the obvious, this is not out of step with America at all.
但该计划以一种有趣的方式绕过了它与基督教的明显相似之处。A.A.称自己是一个精神组织，欢迎个人对更高力量的构想——正如第三步所说的“我们所理解的上帝的照顾”。有很多A.A.文献解释说，这就是使该组织能够被任何信仰的人（包括无神论者和不可知论者）所接受的原因。A.A.有世俗的分支，但这并不能改变A.A.是一个植根于基督教的组织的事实，无论是在其文献中还是在其思维方式上。显而易见，这与美国完全一致。
Christianity appears in what we are told are secular spaces all the time. One Nation under God was added to the Pledge of Allegiance in 1950. during the Cold War. The Girl Scouts still pledge to serve God in my country, and that's not to get into the conservative Christian values that have trickled into crucial legislation. We could be here all day. Let's not forget that the likely creator of the chip was a nun.
基督教经常出现在我们被告知是世俗的空间里。1950年冷战期间，“上帝之下的国家”（One Nation under God）被加入到效忠誓词中。女童子军仍然宣誓效忠上帝和我的国家，这还不算那些渗透到关键立法中的保守派基督教价值观。我们可以在这里待上一整天。别忘了，筹码的创造者很可能是一位修女。
So suppose you are not responsive to AA, and maybe you just want to drink less without surrendering yourself to God. What are your options? The good news is they have. exist, but they're harder to find, and none that I've heard of involve those cool chips. Alternatives include programs like moderation management and smart recovery. Smart recovery takes a secular, cognitive behavioral approach to sobriety, and most courts will accept it the same as they accept AA.
所以，假设你对A.A.没有反应，也许你只是想少喝点酒，而不必把自己交给上帝。你有什么选择？好消息是它们确实存在，但很难找到，而且我听说没有一个涉及那些酷炫的筹码。替代方案包括“节制管理”（Moderation Management）和“智能恢复”（SMART Recovery）等项目。智能恢复采取一种世俗的、认知行为的方法来戒酒，大多数法院会像接受A.A.一样接受它。
There's harm reduction, which seeks to reduce how much of a substance you use without demanding abstinence in trying to remove this process from shes. shame. There are also medication options, most notably naltrexone, which has a solid track record of reducing alcohol cravings, though these cost money or require health insurance. So while there are alternatives, the difficult thing about accessing them is, both in free down-the-street AA and behind the gabled walls of fancy rehab clinics are pretty thoroughly sold on 12-step programs as the option capital O, making these alternatives much harder to come by or to find. And that's to say nothing of cost, because AA is probably the largest mutual aid support network in the country
还有“减少伤害”（harm reduction），它旨在减少你使用的物质数量，而不要求禁欲，并试图将这个过程从羞耻中剥离出来。还有药物选择，最著名的是纳曲酮（naltrexone），它在减少酒精渴望方面有良好的记录，尽管这些需要花钱或需要医疗保险。因此，虽然有替代方案，但获取它们的困难在于，无论是免费的街头A.A.还是昂贵的康复诊所，都非常彻底地推销12步计划作为“大写O”的选择，使得这些替代方案更难获得或找到。这还不算成本，因为A.A.可能是全国最大的互助支持网络，
outside of the church itself and is not going to be beat in that department. So I'm standing with this little white chip in my hand. That's right, we're back. And I'm trying to decide what it means. Because of how AA keeps records, it's not really possible to know. how effective the program is, though that will never stop people from trying. In the late 2000s, there was a very controversial and contested study on 12-step programs that rated them as low as 7% effective. But most recently, a thorough review of all of the existing studies done in 2020 showed that 42% of people participating in AA are completely abstinent a year later. And that's great, as long as you don't think too hard about the number of people who are affected by alcohol
除了教会本身，在这一领域是无法被击败的。所以我手里拿着这个白色的小筹码站着。没错，我们回来了。我正试图决定它意味着什么。由于A.A.保存记录的方式，不可能真正知道该计划有多有效，尽管这永远不会阻止人们尝试。2000年代末，有一项关于12步计划的非常有争议且备受质疑的研究，将其有效性评为低至7%。但最近，2020年对所有现有研究的一项彻底审查显示，42%参加A.A.的人在一年后完全戒酒。这很好，只要你不去深究那些受酒精影响的人数，
use disorder who may not feel welcome or that the program could ever be for them. But at the end of the day, all you have to go on is your own experience. Because as I said before, when AA works for someone, it really works. It's something that my own family was completely changed by. And for many, many members finding the community, the spiritual practice, the sponsorship, or any combination of the three is miraculous. But what seems to work the best is the community. That's what studies consistently show about AA, the effectiveness of its community and structure, a place to go and people to talk to that are not connected to using. And no matter how you feel about AA, it is inescapably American. It's dogma that insists it isn't dogma.
他们可能觉得不受欢迎，或者觉得这个计划永远不适合他们。但归根结底，你只能依靠自己的经验。因为正如我之前所说，当A.A.对某人有效时，它确实非常有效。这是我自己的家庭被彻底改变的事情。对于许多许多成员来说，找到社区、精神实践、赞助人，或三者的任何组合都是奇迹。但看起来最有效的是社区。研究一致表明A.A.的有效性在于其社区和结构，一个可以去的地方和可以交谈的人，他们与使用物质无关。无论你对A.A.感觉如何，它都是不可避免的美国式产物。它是一种坚持自己不是教条的教条。
It's connected to this lineage of government as religion, and it so often fails to create or maintain the safe, inclusive environment that it spent nearly a century marketing itself as having. A fear of being judged by God and by your peers, of losing those chips you spent all that time and energy committing to, the necessity that you view yourself as powerless. While researching this episode, I've been to AA meetings in three states. I've been to smart recovery.
它与这种将政府视为宗教的血统相连，而且它经常无法创造或维持它花了近一个世纪营销自己所拥有的安全、包容的环境。害怕被上帝和同伴评判，害怕失去那些你投入了所有时间和精力承诺的筹码，害怕必须将自己视为无能为力。在研究这一集时，我去了三个州的A.A.会议。我去过智能恢复。
I've been to moderation management. Hell, I've been to the sober faction at the Satanic Temple. They have Zoom meetings. And I've gotten something different out of all of them. I like hearing people's stories, even if I personally wouldn't get biblical about it. I like the idea of taking a searching and fearless inventory of myself, even if I don't think a sponsor should be the one to decide whether I've successfully done so or not. I like the CBT practice of talking through alternative coping.
我去过节制管理。见鬼，我还去过撒旦神庙的清醒派系。他们有Zoom会议。我从所有这些中得到了不同的东西。我喜欢听人们的故事，即使我个人不会把它变得像圣经一样。我喜欢对自己进行彻底而无畏的盘点的想法，即使我不认为赞助人应该是决定我是否成功做到这一点的人。我喜欢谈论替代应对机制的CBT练习。
But I take that little white ship I got that day in Iowa around in my wallet. It probably wouldn't mean a hell of a lot in an AA setting, but I have it with me as a reminder that I have the power to decide what it means. So much of the Prohibition era was about women getting a modicum of power, and I just cannot sit with the idea that a century later, we are being asked to walk down the street and give it away. The chip is a chance to pause before acting, a reminder that I have choices and that there is a community out there.
但我把那天在爱荷华州得到的那个白色小筹码放在钱包里。它在A.A.的环境中可能意义不大，但我把它带在身边，提醒我有权决定它意味着什么。禁酒令时代很大程度上是关于女性获得一点点权力，我实在无法接受一个世纪后，我们被要求走在街上把它拱手相让。筹码是一个在行动前暂停的机会，提醒我有选择，外面有一个社区。
It's a reminder that the community that saved your dad might have changed the family's lives, but that doesn't mean it's your solution. It's a reminder that you have to choose because policing morality will get you nothing but repealed by Franklin D. Roosevelt. It's a reminder that everyone, Every single person deserves an accessible option that works for them, even though that is not remotely the history of the United States. So for now, I'm hanging on to the chip and I'm going to keep working on it.
它提醒你，拯救你父亲的社区可能改变了家庭的生活，但这并不意味着它是你的解决方案。它提醒你，你必须做出选择，因为监管道德除了被富兰克林·D·罗斯福废除外，什么也得不到。它提醒你，每个人，每一个单个人都应该得到一个适合他们的可及选择，尽管这远非美国的历史。所以现在，我紧紧抓住这个筹码，我会继续努力。
One, it's hard to avoid saying it, and I'm going to keep working on it in 24-hour increments. Jamie Loftus is an Emmy-nominated comedy writer, New York Times best-selling author and podcaster. first novel, The Tower, will be available in June 2027, but it's currently available for pre-order right now. Go get it. Everything Jamie does is insightful and funny and cannot be missed. This was our 20th episode of our 100 episode series. And so we're going to take a quick two-week break. And one of the projects that we'll be doing on our break is going through your emails and researching them as potential episodes. So this is a great time to send in your suggestions about what objects you think tell the history of the country.
第一，很难避免说出来，我会以24小时为单位继续努力。杰米·洛夫特斯（Jamie Loftus）是一位获得艾美奖提名的喜剧作家、《纽约时报》畅销书作者和播客主持人。第一部小说《塔》（The Tower）将于2027年6月上市，但目前已经可以预订。去买吧。杰米所做的一切都富有洞察力且有趣，不容错过。这是我们100集系列节目的第20集。所以我们将进行为期两周的短暂休息。我们在休息期间要做的项目之一是浏览你们的电子邮件，并将它们作为潜在的剧集进行研究。所以现在是发送你认为讲述国家历史的物品建议的好时机。
You've already made some great suggestions, and you'll hear those stories in future weeks, and I don't want to spoil them for you, but they're super good. Thank you so much for sending those in. If you want some direction or guidance about things we're looking for right now, we're specifically looking for objects that tell the history of labor struggles in the United States or something that might bring us into the Great Depression, or capture something about the history of immigration,
你们已经提出了一些很好的建议，你们将在未来的几周里听到这些故事，我不想给你们剧透，但它们真的非常好。非常感谢你们发送这些建议。如果你需要关于我们目前正在寻找的东西的方向或指导，我们特别寻找讲述美国劳工斗争历史的物品，或者可能带我们进入大萧条的东西，或者捕捉关于移民历史的东西，
or tell an important tale from American science. So if you have any ideas about those or any other stories, send them to us at 100 Objects at 99PI.org. We'll be back in your feed in three weeks. A history of the United States and 100 Objects is a production of 99% Invisible and BBC Studios. It's hosted and curated by me, Roman Mars. This episode was produced by Jamie Loftus. This series was edited by Annie Brown and Courtney Harrell, mixing by Charlie Brandon King. Fact-checking by Amy Bracken.
或者讲述一个重要的美国科学故事。所以如果你有关于这些或其他故事的想法，请发送到100 Objects at 99PI.org。我们将在三周后回到你们的订阅源中。《美国历史与100件物品》是99% Invisible和BBC Studios的制作。由我，罗曼·马斯（Roman Mars）主持和策划。本集由杰米·洛夫特斯制作。本系列由安妮·布朗（Annie Brown）和考特尼·哈雷尔（Courtney Harrell）编辑，查理·布兰登·金（Charlie Brandon King）混音。事实核查由艾米·布拉肯（Amy Bracken）完成。
Our theme song is by Swan Real. From 99% Invisible, our executive producer is Kathy 2. From BBC Studios, our executive producers are Annie Brown and Courtney Harrell. Our production coordinator is Shan Palais, and the production manager is Mabel Finnegan Wright. Artwork by Stefan Lawrence. 99% Invisible is part of the Sirius XM podcast family, headquartered in Beautiful,
我们的主题曲由Swan Real创作。来自99% Invisible，我们的执行制片人是凯西·2（Kathy 2）。来自BBC Studios，我们的执行制片人是安妮·布朗和考特尼·哈雷尔。我们的制作协调员是珊·帕莱（Shan Palais），制作经理是梅布尔·芬尼根·赖特（Mabel Finnegan Wright）。艺术作品由斯特凡·劳伦斯（Stefan Lawrence）创作。99% Invisible是Sirius XM播客家族的一部分，总部位于美丽的，
Uptown, Oakland, California, and BBC Studios is headquartered in Beautiful, White City, West London. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
加利福尼亚州奥克兰市住宅区，BBC Studios总部位于美丽的伦敦西部白城。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。